[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver vous allez
voir nos quatre invités sont au taquet
dans ce studio pour parler de quatre
sujets qu'on va découvrir tout de suite
en images
on va revenir sur l'interview de ce
matin du premier ministre à deux
confrères d'rtl
il a annoncé des mesures pour faciliter
la vie des français qui ont du mal à
payer leur plein de gasoil et aussi de
fioul
est-ce que ça a suffi pour éteindre
l'incendié vous lui donnerez votre point
de vue nous reviendrons aussi sur cette
tempête de tweets que donald trump a
envoyé hier sur la france et sur
emmanuel macron et s'il avait raison
et s'il faisait juste renvoyé ce il
renvoyait juste la monnaie de sa pièce à
emmanuel macron qu'il aurait mal
accueillie c'est une hypothèse vous le
dire est ce que vous en pensez
et puis peut-être le savez vous le
gouvernement italien avait jusqu'à hier
minuit pour amender son projet de budget
pour l'année prochaine sa dépense trop
dit bruxelles sauf que le gouvernement
italien veut pas bouger
et s'il faisait sauter l'europe on va se
poser la question et puis on va
s'intéresser aussi à l'interview que
doit donner ce soir emmanuel macron à 20
heures chez nos confrères de tf1 il sera
en direct du porte avions charles de
gaulle
que peux-tu te dire pour essayer de
calmer la colère des français celle qui
pourrait s'exprimer samedi prochain est
bien là aussi on s'interrogera avec nos
quatre invités bonsoir judith waintraub
vous êtes grand reporter au figaro
magazine et on vous retrouve
régulièrement sur de nombreuses chaînes
d'information continue comme votre
voisin andré bercoff d'ailleurs
écrivains journalistes vous êtes aussi
l'animateur de la quotidienne 12 13
heures chez nos confrères de sud radio
est votre dernier livre donald trump les
raisons de la colère a été publié aux
éditions first
on rappellera que vous êtes toujours à
ma connaissance le seul journaliste
français avoir interviewé donald
régentant de rester et c'est ce que j'ai
donné des instructions en ce sens c'est
dire que vous êtes un homme influent
matthieu aron est là aussi bon soir vous
êtes grand reporter et conseiller
éditorial à l'ops loeb ce qui n'est pas
encore sorti puisque le journal sort
demain votre dernier livre grandes
plaidoiries des ténors du barreau a été
publié aux éditions mareuil c'est aussi
un grand succès au théâtre avec richard
berry à partir du mois prochain on
pourra le
retrouvez au théâtre comédia c'est bien
ça peut-être
et puis alexis lacroix est là aussi bon
soir alexis vôtre vous êtes directeur
délégué de la rédaction de l'express
l'express qui lui est sorti et qui nous
régale cette semaine une couverture sur
un gîte brigitte maquereau et le rôle
qu'elle joue votre dernier livre
j'accuse 1898 2018 nos portes noir au
rythme actuel en ti c mon visionnant sur
un sujet autrement plus graves et il a
été publié aux édition de l'observatoire
on commence par l'interview du premier
ministre edouard philippe était ce matin
chez nos confrères d'rtl donc dans la
perspective du mouvement des gilets
jaunes de samedi il a essayé de calmer
les français on va l'écouter
ce matin c'était noël en novembre
première mesure nous allons développer
et développer massivement la prime à la
conversion automobile aujourd'hui vous
avez des primes à la conversion elles
peuvent remonter à 2000 euros
nous allons faire en sorte que pour les
20 % des français les plus modestes une
super prime soit créée qui permettra de
passer à 4000 euros
on va augmenter le chèque énergie nous
allons développer la prime à la
conversion mais cette fois-ci non pas
automobile mais des chaudières pour
faire en sorte que les français puissent
là aussi se libérer de cette contrainte
extraordinaire d'utiliser le fioul pour
se chauffer alors c'est un montage
réalisé par charlotte darche s'est pas
en direct le premier ministre qui
balance comme ça ces mesures par rafales
il y en avait eu encore je crois qu'ils
étaient celles de l'augmentation du
barème kilométrique pour les gens qui
déclarent leurs kilomètres pour les
faire passer en frais professionnels
alexis lacroix est ce que vous pensez
que ça a rassuré les français qui
s'inquiétaient pour leur pouvoir d'achat
en tout cas si vous voulez samson jouer
les madame soleil parce qu'on verra bien
samedi lors de la première mobilisation
de ces gilet jaune
après tout elle s'annonce quand même
comme assez coriace je crois néanmoins
là c'est une parole de responsabilité il
a il a prononcé quelques a d'abord il a
énoncé les mesures qui viennent d'être
rappelés dans votre sujet et il a
prononcé je crois quelques paroles assez
apaisante suffiront-elles ça c'est la
grande question mais quand même il ya
aussi un deuxième deuxième partie du
match qui va se jouer vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure guillaume ce soir
en direct du charles de gaulle c'est le
président de la république donc c'est le
crous
une qui va peut-être tendre une main
fraternelle à ces français en colère en
tout cas essayer d'apaiser leur colère
toujours est il qu'ils se débattent et
ça c'est disons le rapidement pour
l'intelligibilité de ce débat actuel ils
se débattent dans une sorte de double
bind parce que d'un côté il est vrai il
est vrai qu'il faut écouter la
protestation de ces millions
d'automobilistes qui focalisent ou qui
cristallisent leur mécontentement sur
cette question de la de la taxe car il
faut pas non plus reculer trop mais il
l'a dit d'ailleurs fils edouard philippe
l'a dit je pense que c'est pas que dans
sa bouche du wishful thinking on pays
peuvent pas abandonner la transition
écologique c'est pas possible
la transition écologique elle est au
coeur d'une des promesses du candidat
macron et elle est aussi au coeur d'une
disons qu'on les aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas un mais elle est au coeur de la
modernité politique
eh bien s'ils disent la transition
écologique finalement on s'en fout parce
qu'on a peur des automobilistes alors là
je vais vous dire le déni que ça
représenterait par rapport à leur
promesse serait absolument terrible et
sans doute bomb a été révisé par
l'instruction de la france par quelque
part quelques mécontents que vous avez
été plutôt convaincu par edouard filet
pour vous pose la question sur twitter
un à vos chers internautes qui sommes en
train de nous écouter pas encore un
petit peu de chemin pour qu'ils soient
convaincus puisque vous êtes 81% à de
dire non nous n'avons pas été comme un
vrai dire ce qui est vrai c'est que
c'était avant qu'on écoute alexis
lacroix donc peut-être qu'on a changé la
vie tout bouleverser guillaume est
soulagé alexis lacroix je suis assez
content parce que j'entends jour le
bouchon est mon point de le chouette
mans l élite de non non non de la brosse
à reluire une jolie brosse à reluire
je m'explique mais j'adore avec cécile à
trois sur moi je ne trouve pas plus
éloignés de la macro dit que moi ya pas
non mais à l'ol
alors au delà de cette attention à ces
personnels chez andré bercoff je m'étais
rendu d'abord je trouve assez
hallucinant que le brave edouard
philippe
dans des choses mais leur coût ne
l'utile donné avant pourquoi aujourd'hui
selon la menace est évidemment de ce
qu'il sent arriver et ce qui arrive et
je ne sais pas tu seras massive ou pas
on va pas jouer madame soleil il est
évident que quelque chose se passe mais
moi je suis fascinée
par ses gouvernants qui quand même donne
ici une impression excusez-moi de
panique car s'il n'y avait pas la
panique
si c'est ce qui me dit pourquoi ne l'at
il pas dit plus tôt puisque c'est
faisable puisque c'est gérable puisque
ses comptables
pourquoi n'at-il pas les plus tôt qui
pourrait faire la prime à ceux ci lui la
conversion à ceci les primes à cela et
aider ça c'est typiquement l'erreur
tragique de ces braves gens attention de
gauche comme de droite
je suis pas en train de dire qu'il ya
que le gamin macron qui est responsable
de ça il y a quand même un problème qui
est grave qui est qu' il faut attendre
que les gens qu'une manifestation qui ne
s'est pas encore passé menaces là c'est
pour dire attendez attendez on l'a jules
est on va lâcher du lest si c'est pas un
aveu de faiblesse je voudrais savoir ce
que c'est bah je vais retrouver leur a
au moins servi à ça cette manifestation
des gilet jaune
oui mais le gouvernement l'exécutif à un
double problème en français à mon avis
c'est un problème de crédibilité d'abord
sur la réalité des sommes consacrées à
la transition énergétique tous les
français ont compris que vania mâcon ne
baissez pas les dépenses contrairement à
ce qu'il avait promis
donc premier vice de forme quand edouard
philippe se défendent des chiffres qui
sont inattaquables à savoir que seuls 20
% de l'augmentation ira effectivement la
transition écologique en dix ans mais
regardez le budget du ministère la
transition écologistes et 34 milliards
et ça tombe très bien parce que
la hausse des carburants c'est aussi 34
milliards donc ça donne atteint sur le
carburant les taxes c'est quand même un
argument un peu léger dans le problème
de crédibilité eu égard au reste de la
politique qui quand même et du
ras-le-bol fiscale qui est y sert de
décor à ce mouvement dès gilet jaune
et puis à problèmes de réalisme parce
que on vous explique à matignon comme
ailleurs qu'on fait du signal prix c'est
à dire qu'on veut décourager les gens
d'employer les carburants les plus
polluants en augmentant leurs prix mais
le signal prix n'était efficace que si
elle choix quand vous vous adressez à
quelqu'un qui n'a pas le choix soit
d'utiliser ce mode de carburant soit
deux pas du tout d'abord deux chaudières
une au gasoil et il a est rare de vous
préférez ça déboite ou août vous même de
préférer sa voiture diesel quand on a un
train à proximité ou enfin des
transports collectifs
la réalisation a été une folie et
seulement comme on le dirait pas tout de
suite hier alexis lacroix crash dit
n'avait pas faire bercy j'avais besoin
d'entendre très bientôt matthieu aron et
avant cela nos internautes avec leurs
commentaires
avec élan sur lefigaro.fr qui nous lie
c'est une grosse blague edouard philippe
je verse une prime avec l'argent des
autres pour en aider certains à payer
une taxe anti mac état est assez
d'accord on nous met des taxes pure nous
annonce des mesures compensatoires
où est la cohérence et monsieur babineau
nous dit sur le fond le gouvernement ne
recule pas c'est de la com c'est assez
juste matière ont finalement tout ce
qu'on pouvait attendre de concret du
premier ministre c'était de renoncer à
cette taxation nouvelle et c'est pas le
cas le problème c'est que le dispositif
en ont fait va plutôt effectivement dans
le sens de la transition écologique
donc ça dispositif qui n'est pas une
intelligente mais c'est un dispositif
totalement inaudible je crois que ça ne
sert strictement à rien ce qui a fait
les douars philippe ce matin ça ne sert
à rien parce qu'il est face à des gens
qui sont en colère et qui ont une envie
profonde c'est de manifester leur colère
donc quoi qu'on leur annonce aujourd'hui
quoique le président macron sauf s'il
revient surtout s il dit
baisse effectivement toutes les taxes
sur les carburants ce que je ne pense
pas il ne le fera pas à partir de là il
y aura cette colère qui va s'exprimer et
je crois que dans cette colère s'exprime
non seulement effectivement la réaction
des gens vis-à-vis de la hausse des
taxes sur les carburants mais bien
d'autres choses est ce que paye
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
incontestablement c'est le début de son
septennat c'est le fait d'être apparu
comme le président des riches donc on a
d'un côté quelqu'un qui est apparu comme
ça comme le président des riches et en
face des gens qui voient les carburants
qui montrent qu'ils voient que c'est
cher de se chauffer cher de se déplacer
et à partir de là quels que soient les
autres mesures qui existent par ailleurs
comme le fait qu' effectivement beaucoup
de français en tout cas les salariés
aient vu leurs bulletins de salaire
monter au mois d'octobre et personne ou
presque n'a remarqué avec l'abbé
spécialistes voilà mais en réalité
aujourd'hui il ya des gens mécontents
qui ont envie de le faire savoir et dans
ces cas là il n'y a pas grand-chose à
faire voir quelle va être la hauteur du
mécontentement et ça on n'en sait rien
on le verra partir de samedi
nicole nous dit pourquoi est-ce que
emmanuel macron adore filet pour laisser
la sncf fermer les petites lignes
allusion à propos de judith waintraub et
puis le premier ministre matin il a
parlé du bon lolo est ce que vous saviez
ce que c'était que le boulot
depuis donc le boulot c'est le sait le 7
à une expo africains pour désigner une
forme de désordre mais finalement avec
le recul est ce qu on préfère que vous
pensez que edouard philippe aurait mieux
fait de ne rien annoncer
parce qu'on se dit que tous les gens qui
pourront pas profiter de ces mesures là
vont être encore plus mécontent témoin
je n'aime pas beaucoup la communication
mais là je vois parler de communication
ce qui est quand même hallucinant dans
ces cas là il se passe ça qu'ils
attendent de voir ce qui se passe qu'ils
attendent de voir ce que donnera le 17
et à ce moment là on réagit quand on
commence à dire ou pas voilà on va faire
ceci transition écologique beaucoup de
choses à dire de la transition
écologique d'ailleurs qui a bon dos
enfin ça c'est un autre problème
mais à partir du moment où il commence à
dire attendez on va faire ça on va faire
si macro avait commencé on va commencer
à dire un certain nombre de choses mais
qu'est ce qu'ils croient et là je
rejoins matière qu'est ce qu'ils croient
qu'ils vous arrêter à partir de ce
moment il faut dire que jardin disait
que l'amour c'est beaucoup plus que
l'amour là les carburants c'est beaucoup
plus que les carburants sakho là ça
c'est sûr quelque chose et la goutte de
fioul lourd du fait d orsay maladie
justement non mais juste avant qu'on tue
pourra rendre ce que mathieu a dit c'est
à dire qu'effectivement c'est une
cristallisation mais c'est l'occasion
cristallisé une colère qui finalement
n'a rien à voir c'est un battant tu
ferais tout pour diviser l'ennemi tous
les gilet jaune sont pas des
paranoïaques populiste certains sont
simplement des gens qui expriment
d'exaspération éventuellement passagère
et occitane on attendait quand tu fais
de la politique
tu es tu es à l'arrêt qu'il fallait
faire et battu lâche du lest face à
l'ennemi mais je crache du feu
donc vous pensez que vous devenez bien
sûr que tu essayes de diviser l'ennemi
il ya des radicaux ya des radicaux comme
bercoff qui sont des gilet jaune
inexpiable emile thomas avec sont plus
modérés qui l'on compte que le premier
ministre et le président sans doute ce
soir sont des gestes font des gestes à
leur endroit
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles les
bagnoles macro est impopulaire c'est que
ces réformes n'ont pas produit de
résultats sur le terrain où on les
attendait le plus c'est à dire bon le
chômage
non je dit patienter nous dit alexis
lacroix qui n'est pas pour autant un
soutien de nos mac rumors gematik c'est
un outil ma chronique j'ai jamais bien
intime acronis aussi fort à cet
excellent tim akrour mais moi ça veut
dire de voir ça alors y en a un autre
qui est assez franchement anti macro
c'est donald trump qui nous a régalé
hier de ce qu'on appelle aux états unis
le morning twitts temps on c'est à dire
la tempête des tweets du matin le
président le président américain une
fois rentré à washington après son
séjour en france a expliqué que emmanuel
macron j'ai très impopulaire parce que
le chômage en france étaient élevées que
les français apprenez l'allemand pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale avant que
les américains ne vienne les sauver et
que de toute façon il ne refuse
d'apporter du vin américain tout ça
évidemment ce sont des réponses à
l'accueil un peu frais qui lui avait été
réservé pour les cérémonies du 11
novembre
peut-être donc que c'était justifié
cette réaction en tout cas c'est pas du
tout la vie de benjamin griveaux le
porte parole du gouvernement qu'ils
accusent en anglais dans le texte
un manque de décence regarder je réponde
en deux mots sur ses tweets
hier c'était le 13 novembre nous
commémorions l'assassinât de 130 de nos
compatriotes
il ya trois ans à paris et à saint denis
donc je vais répondre en anglais common
decency ont été de bon aloi je deviens
trop bon c'était peut-être pas le jour
pour pour ses réactions ça on laisse à
l'appréciation des internautes qui nous
suivent mais sur le fond est ce que des
intrus bavay raison de taper du poing
sur la table comme ça à la forme est
évidemment très discutable c'est du
trump
on est habitué c'est quand même mâcon
qui a ouvert les hostilités
quand il a parlé de cette armée
européenne dans l'une des vocations sera
elle aussi de nous protéger contre les
états unis
la chine la russie alors après on a eu
des communiqués les lignes nous
expliquant qu'on a mal compris qu'il
s'agissait du cyberespace est en fait il
s'agissait vraiment d'une armée
européenne et est destiné à nous
protéger contre les états unis donc
c'est vrai que donald trump mal le
prendre
étant donné les efforts que les états
unis fournissent pour nous protéger du
terrorisme qui reste notre ennemi commun
je lisais que depuis le 11 septembre les
états unis avaient investi plus de 2800
milliards de dollars dans la lutte
antiterroriste l'europe ne peut pas en
dire autant
le haut prélat comme je le disais vous
êtes le seul journaliste français à
avoir jamais interviewé donald trump qu
est ce qu a dans sa tête mais écoutez
moi il m'avait parlé quand j'ai juste
souri vanier un asus quand je les ai vus
il ya deux ans deux ans et demi non
c'était avant c'était un moment des
réactions des républicains
bah il m'avait parlé du bataclan
longuement quand j'arrive au jury
reparle de commander sens il faudrait
qu'il se regarde dans la glace car on ne
sait mais il faut le dire ses rouages de
cette expression où les liens je sais
moreau elle sera lé grimaud c'est
grimaud et griveaux et griveaux
s'écrivent rôle
nous confondons pas les torchons et les
serviettes pourquoi je dis ça parce que
quand on parle de commander c'est si on
eût été mais qui emmanuel macron qui se
produit partout qui a fait son unité
dans ce mémorial accompagnent il ya eu
plusieurs défilés il ya eu plusieurs
manifestations pour commémorer le 13
novembre macro n'y était pas or il adore
les commémorations on aurait aimé qu'il
ya là comme un des six deuxièmement
juste pour tromper je suis pas pour le
défendre c'est quelqu'un mal élevés qui
mange avec les doigts tout ce que vous
voulez etc
il n'empêche qu'il ya eu l'armée
européens dont a parlé jeudi mais il ya
autre chose voulue la personne qui a
chanté qui s'appelle angélique kidjo qui
a chanté cet in africa chanteuse
béninoise chanteuse béninoise a été à
washington est la première à manifester
contre up sur les institutions elle a
été très en pointe par tous les médias
américains d'être un pet attirant train
péta dictateur etc etc
choisir je veux bien mais c'est pas par
hasard qu'on ne me dise pas que une
personne n'a dit
même la con qu'un jet li ti jo le
présenter devant trump c'était un peu et
troisièmement c'est comme ça si allen
comme par hasard
macron données interview à cnn qui est
l'ennemi juré de 30
donc on ne peut pas dire que tout ça a
été extrêmement accueillants alors lui
répond à sa manière que tu m'as hier
effectivement très brut de décoffrage
mais il faudra il faut le rappeler ça
vous pose la question sur twitter un
soutenez vous les critiques faites sur
la france et sur emmanuel macron par
donald trump
c'est assez équilibré vous êtes majorité
à dire que non mais quand même on sent
que ça vaut ça vous intéresse quand même
et que vous n'êtes pas totalement dans
la condamnation
matthieu aron vous croyez par exemple
que sur ce sujet de la chanteuse
béninoise donc il y a qui as est
intervenu pendant la commémoration donc
devant donald trump ou pensé que c'était
fait exprès par emmanuel macron que
l'objectif était de provoquer trummer
j'ai goûté un jour c'est rien du tout je
vais tout à fait franc avec vous en
revanche moi je pense que donald trump
même s'ils mangent avec ses doigts
quelque part je pense qu'il y aura le
meilleur des services aujourd'hui parce
que on a un président de la république
qu'il a un gros problème de popularité
dans son pays on a un président de la
république qui avait perdu quelque peu
de crédibilité ces derniers mois or là
il se retrouve la cible de donald trump
et tout d'un coup on se dit tiens ça lui
donne un statut particulier
là dessus je pense que emmanuel mâcon
pourrait se saisir de ce moment
j'entendais ce matin dominique de
villepin sur france inter qui disait
quelque chose que je trouvais assez
intéressante qui expliquait que dans la
campagne européenne et dans les mois à
venir
emmanuel macron avait peut-être intérêt
à essayer de fédérer l'europe contre les
ennemis de l'europe ou contre les gens
qui ne sont pas forcément les meilleurs
amis de l'europe pour le dire plus tôt
comme ça c'est à dire la chine c'est à
dire la russie mais c'est aussi notre
meilleur ennemi amis les états unis et
qu'à partir de là plutôt que de dénoncer
des nationalismes européens les
populismes européennes pour voir comment
un esprit européen pouvait se révéler
face aux autres grands continents je dis
ça aujourd'hui
ce matin j'ai lu dans un très bon
journal de votre le figaro c'est note de
la dgse qui explique pourquoi
effectivement les états unis d'amérique
continue parce que c'est pas nouveau
continue à espionner
effectivement toutes les grandes
entreprises européennes et françaises en
particulier
comment on fait que à travers une extra
territorialité de leurs droits les etats
unis continuent à exercer une forme de
domination économique sur le monde voilà
des choses qui sont pas inintéressantes
donc pourrait peut-être s'emparer
emmanuel macron et certains européens
alors vous disiez que vous aviez écouté
dominique de villepin ce matin sur
france inter
eh bien nous aussi mal et il se trouve
que il est revenu sur ses tweets où on
lui a posé la question quel est leur
objectif
à votre avis et pour lui c'est clair il
s'agissait de répondre à ce que l'ancien
premier ministre appelle une humiliation
il y avait un deuxième objectif qui est
sans doute répondre à l'humiliation
qu'il a ressenti pendant ces cérémonies
à la fois de ne pas être au centre de
ces cérémonies alors que manifestement
le voile ans et 8 pour lui le grand
acteur de tous la première guerre et
deuxième guerres ce sont les états unis
qui la france doit douanes devrait tout
il ya un autre élément d'humiliation qui
est la mise en cause du nationalisme
américain par le président français il
avec celle à quoi on a humilié être une
certaine manière nous n'avaons le
mobilisation il est trop fort vent
dominique de villepin pourtant je crois
me semblait connaissait la langue
française mais là à mon avis il
n'utilise pas le bon mot non en revanche
il a été c'est vrai un peu relégués
symboliquement mais pour la raison que
ni mathieu c'est dire qu'effectivement
dans la tête du président il se rend
bien compte que jouer le rempart
européens contre les salvini et l'urban
c'est bien mais c'est pas suffisant
ce qu'il faut faire et c'est ce qu'ils
vont faire c'est à allal approche des
échéances de ces élections européennes
si importante
il va se poser en rempart de l'idée
européenne contre tous ses ennemis
extérieurs et évidemment ce qui a été
ressenti comme une humiliation là pour
le coup c'est pas le statut symbolique
du président américain dans l'est comme
dans le le périple mémorielle qu'on
évoquait à l'instant c'est pas ça c'est
le fait que évoquant cette armée
européenne à venir
ils les englober les états unis parmi
les nouvelles tyrannie potentiels qui
sont un danger pour le modèle européen
des mots pour pour le fonds le modèle
européen démocratique et humaniste et à
titre personnel je pense que pour le
coup pas redondante à une expression
américaine un peu vulgaire mais ça pour
le coup dans la bouche de macron c'est
too much
on ne peut pas mettre sur le même plan
la chine ou la russie actuelle et les
états unis même gouverné par l'ami
d'andré bercoff voit la prévert que je
rappelle quelque chose quand même une
petite phrase c'est que il a parlé de
l'otan il a dit c'est très bien armées
européennes mais peut-être pour y mettre
un peu plus d'argent dans l'otan je
rappelle que les américaines m 16 105
milliards 3,2 pour cent de pib financer
l'otan la france est moins de 2 % et
l'allemagne aussi donc quand il dit
écoutez vous pourriez peut-être à mettre
un peu plus de contributions c'était
joli monnaies très content de voir
l'otan moi je ne suis pas le poème est
alors quand vous parlez vous dites il a
rendu service au président m'a confessé
leur ait pu lui non il aurait pu rendre
service au président macron si l'europe
existaient mais de quoi on parle
quelle europe l'europe de corbas vous
croyez qu'elle est plus avec macron
qu'avec trump le roi peu de salvini
l'europe de deux des tchèques et
slovaques
l'europe est aujourd'hui et heureusement
qu'il ya l'euro l'europe
enfin disons le il ya un processus de
désintégration de fonds alors d'un côté
vous dites à ces [ __ ] de populiste
c'est l'épreuve populiste se disait
macro et il va les réunir maintenant
c'est les propos pub à soyons sérieux où
vous voulez réunir l'europe et vous
acceptez l'europe telle que les peuples
européens ont élu leur leader ou alors
on ne l'accepté pas c'est pour ça que
tout ça c'est de la rhétorique et qui
s'arrêtent là je crois en moi je dirais
pas de la rhétorique irait de
l'improvisation parce que cette histoire
d'armée européenne donc il s'agit bien
mais au sens concret et pas du tout
virtuel du terme d'un l'approbation d'à
peu près personne angela merkel a dit
qu'elle l'a prouvé mais elle n'a pas
approuvé l'initiative européenne de
défense qui est quand même un geste
concret est à la base de qui doit servir
de cadre à une défense européenne plus
coordonnés mais en plus jean yves le
drian quand il inaugurait la chaire de
stratégie à la sorbonne en 2016 a dit
explicitement plutôt que de fantasmer
sur une armée européenne imaginaire il
faudrait commencer par avoir d'avant de
pas manifester davantage de solidarité
entre repères arnaud danjean qui est
venue elle macron avait chargé d'un
rapport sur la stratégie a dit que
c'était ni fait ni à faire et je
pourrais continuer longtemps par exemple
par jean christophe lagarde qui sont c
est plutôt bienveillant le centriste et
je disais à vie oui mais il a élargi la
personne sait qu'il tient non mais la
réflexion de la réflexion
la réflexion de maquereaux explique
yannick c'est l'idée qu'on existe à
l'objection désignant de cette mine en
voilà et aujourd'hui macron à l'idée
qu'il va désigner les ennemis de
l'europe non non non c'est de la
politique
l'idée qu'on va désigner les ennemis de
l'europe et lui permettre dont de
fortifier son existence chanceux l'on
sait c'est de la politique selon carl
schmitt c'est à dire vous vous
définissez vous même vous désirez pas il
est vrai qu'elle est non c'est le
monsieur rigoler parce que vous êtes des
rats sains mais vous vous fortifiée vous
même vous fortifiée vous même en
définition vos ennemis or aujourd'hui
macron là il n'a pas tort de dire les
vérités l'ennemi de la fin non je dis je
vais je dis j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il avait tort d'y inclure il a pas
tort de dire la chine et la russie ne
veulent pas que l'europe advienne à une
existence souveraine ça c'est vrai et
donc macron va jouer ça dans les mois
qui viennent et donc c'est de la
politique
vous pouvez ne pas être d'accord mais
vous reconnaissez que c'est de la
politique
coq jeu n'ont bien entendu l'amérique ne
va pas rentrer très stupide d'imaginer
même un instant ses possibilités en
guerre demain contre l'europe en guerre
conventionnelle contre lorient mais
l'amérique est en guerre contre l'europe
l'amérique est en guerre contre l'
europe sur un plan économique du sulon
c'est une évidence et les décisions qui
aient pu prendre trump sont des
décisions qui effectivement impacte
considérablement notre économie donc
notre manière de vivre
quand effectivement entre hommes
décident d'établir un embargo sur l'iran
et que les plus grandes sociétés
françaises qui avaient de remarquables
marché qui permet d'avoir effectivement
pour nos industries une capacité de
développement importants sont obligés de
plier bagage oui ça a des conséquences
importantes
ce n'est pas exactement ce que
j'appellerais un geste mon ami qu'elle
attendait vas tu avances pour carlo
n'est pas bon il ne faut pas j'entends
ce que vous dites oui qu'ils ne peuvent
pas avoir de naïveté de naïveté
vis-à-vis des etats-unis d'amérique
mais elle s'en est excusé au bar tabac
tuera jeu gran racim et en particulier
la démocratie me disent oh honey il
n'est pas une grande et belle à voir
mais naïve t par rapport à l'état
européen parce que j'ai ou reprendre
c'est quand même très adresse vous avez
posé l'exemple parfait
vous avez posé l'exemple parfait quand
il ya eu justement la rupture de
l'accord il parle trump avec l'iran
absolument bien qu'elle café macron et
tous les autres ont du bon il est le
moment ça a été la même chose
maquereau en service ou du train pour un
service à mâcon macron a dit il via
l'europe a montré que elle elle va tenir
le coup
quelle est la première qui n'a pas tenu
le coup qui a dit attendez t'es bien
gentil montpetit macron mais moi mais
voiture je me demande c'est madame psa
madame merkel compagnie c'est à dire que
votre construction et est très bien
c'est du wishful thinking
mais ça ne tient pas une minute devant
les vérités je ne veux vraiment pas ça
tout d'amour avec l'état l'isle d'abeau
qui sera
nature je réagissais juste à ce que vous
disiez de la vision vous aviez des états
unis il mais je vais y aller un petit
peu plus loin oui au jour d'aujourd'hui
sur une question comme celle de l'iran
l'europe ne possède pas des outils qui
lui permettent d'avoir une monnaie comme
le dollar qui est la monnaie des
échanges internationaux
il n'empêche il n'empêche que le
ministre allemand de l'économie a
proposé a fait des propositions dans ce
sens là et que ses propositions sont
totalement soutenu par bruno le maire
qui de sa bouche man nous a dit qu'il en
avait un peu marre que les états
européens soient vassaliser cesseront
terme par les états unis
c'est tout ce que je reprenais mais
personne pour dévaliser
je laisse le dernier mot à nos
internautes à nicole qui nous dit une
armée européenne pour l'interrogation
mais qui va commander et qui va payer ce
sont deux excellentes question deux
expulsions de roms
monsieur pierre coffe a raison que
l'europe unie c'est un mirage et on va
en reparler dans quelques instants avec
le cas italien
et puis un petit mode d'anti mac qui
nous dit trump et peut-être grossier
mais macron a été très maladroit et r34
aussi évidemment c'est un pseudonyme
renvoie dos à dos les deux hommes en
disant trump s'est conduit comme un
gougnafier conquérant et macro n'avez
pas à les cibles et presque nommément
dans son discours surtout en ce jour de
11 novembre c'est le en même temps
l'europe pour continuer à en parler avec
le budget italien salaire un peu
technique mais c'est extrêmement
important je vous rappelle les épisodes
précédents
le nouveau pouvoir en italie a prévu un
budget 2010 9 avec un déficit de 2 4% du
pib contre 8 % cette année toute allure
et 2% c'est beaucoup plus que ce que
bruxelles avait demandé à l'italie
sachant qu l'italie est l'un des pays
les plus endettés de la zone euro
donc la commission avait dit vous avez
jusqu'à hier soir minuit pour changer
votre copie et ben italien et changeront
rien du tout luigi di maio qui est à la
fois le vice président du conseil
italien est l'homme fort du mouvement 5
étoiles l'a confirmé hier à rome
marc andré bercoff le l'italie en raison
de passer d écouter il me souvient d'un
certain pierre moscovici vous avez
entendu parler de pierre moscovici qui
il y a trois ou quatre ans disent
écoutez on n'est pas 3% mais vous
n'allez pas nous embêter ne disait pas
comme ça mais le disait presque comme ça
avec 3% effectivement il était visite de
l'économie de françois hollande avait
exactement elle a dit écoutez ça valait
3 % ci reviendra vous n'allez pas
exclusion l'expression nous car et des
pendules parce qu'on n'y est pas
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant oui dans
ce pas son genre du tout le brave homme
moscow et aujourd'hui on dit 2,6 savent
c'est formidable c'est que c'est la
première fois dans son histoire que
l'union européenne rappelle quelqu'un
comme par hasard italie comment vous
êtes à 2,12 n'est pas 2,6 mais vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir encore
une fois moi ce que j'adore cette
indignation sélective des deux poids et
deux mesures
alors moi j'aimerais que nous n'avons
pas possible moi pas du lot on est tous
à l'exemple cher macro lien le problème
est là pourquoi encore une fois à
l'italie le mauvais pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont ces [ __ ] de populiste
comment ils ont voté mal eh ben on va
leur faire comprendre qu'un peuple n'a
pas à voter mal donc nous le résultat et
je crois franchement qui vont s'asseoir
dessus
et qu'est ce que ça va faire alors on a
en mémoire les conséquences oui parce
que ça peut c'est quand même un
précédent un peu fâcheux matthieu aron
c'est la première fois que on dit comme
ça non aussi ouvertement à la commission
parce que ça peut avoir un impact
surtout des pays de la zone euro parce
que ça peut faire peur aux gens qui nous
prêtent de l'argent
c'est alors je ne sais pas la première
fois quand même qu'un pays manifestent
sont beaux nos positions vis-à-vis de
l'organisation sur le budget n'est
précisée alors sur le bord je vais voir
comment la langue
nisation justement comment la commission
va les rappeler à l'ordre parce que j'ai
cru comprendre que ces dernières 24
heures les italiens étaient en train d'
habiller leur demande c'est à dire que
plutôt que de la présenter comme une
demande comme ça massive on explique
aujourd'hui que ça s'explique aussi
parce que le pont de gênes a été détruit
parce que effectivement l'italie a connu
ce qui est vrai des conditions
climatiques qui ont entraîné un déficit
considérable donc il ya une partie
exceptionnelle de graves inondations le
mois dernier moi je ne suis pas trop
inquiet de la réponse européenne et
l'opposition qui aura entre l'italie et
la commission européenne
en revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que au
delà de l'europe elle-même
il ya des marchés financiers et
effectivement on peut supposer que
l'italie aura plus de difficultés compte
tenu de ses choix économiques à
emprunter à un taux qui est déjà élevé
très élevé pour l'état dick 2000 risque
d'être encore plus élevé donc je crois
que ce sont plutôt les marchés
financiers et à quel taux de crédit on
va mettre la dette italienne qui diront
les choses plutôt que l'europe est le
même dans city et puis en grèce dit
prince avait tenté le bras de fer est la
leur ils avaient très vite compris qu'il
n'y avait pas de voie possible enfin si
la voix c'était de la sortie d'europe en
en acceptant les conséquences or
l'italie n'a pas envie de sortir de
l'europe et l'euro ni même de notre ni
même de l'euro et puis surtout l'europe
n'a pas envie de perdre l'italie et n'en
a pas les moyens on est dans une
configuration tout à fait différente on
a des élections européennes où tous les
partis dits populistes et nationalistes
ou menacent de faire des scores très
importants
tous les sociaux démocrates ou presque
sont laminés et quant aux mouvements
centristes puisque emmanuel macron vient
d'annoncer qu'en marche aller rejoindre
le groupe centriste européens sont en
très grande difficulté angela merkel est
extrêmement affaibli les circonstances
plaident vraiment pour un statu quo est
d'ailleurs les les statuts européens
on donne la possibilité puisque la
procédure pour déficit
excessivement ça peut être ouvert
apparemment d'après ce que j'ai compris
d'ici fin janvier
mais ensuite il faudra attendre les
élections puis attendre qu'une nouvelle
commission
sa stature que d'ici à l'automne en gros
l'italie n'a pas grand chose à mon avis
à craindre sur twitter à voodoo dit que
oui l'italie a raison de ne pas changer
son budget pour 2010 neuf en tout cas
vous êtes 67 % de ceux qui nous écoutent
et on rappellera jamais assez que ce
n'est pas un sondage à considérer cela
et puis il ya une sorte de deux coeurs
presque unanime contre ce mal euros
pierre moscovici qui est le commissaire
européen qui suit ces sujets je vous le
rappelle albert sur lefigaro.fr nous dit
pendant des années la france n'a pas
respecté les règles et moscovici hausse
faire la leçon
moscovici ex-ministre de hollande en
donneur de leçons à mourir de rire et
nicole qui nous dit moscovici un des
plus mauvais ministre de l'économie et
qui donne des leçons à l'italie tout en
accordant un satisfecit à la france et
est rejoint par nos sites
cette vie formule bien connue cordonnier
est maître chez lui oui mais ici il faut
vous voyez vos auditeurs sont des gens
très respectables mais ceux d'entre eux
qui sont prêts nommément avec cette
espèce de jouissance dont le bashing en
outrage à moscovici font une erreur
moscovici d'abord ça a été un très bon
ministre de l'économie et du budget ça
c'est d'être promu en 1re manche et puis
là aujourd'hui il est dans son rôle
c'est à dire que le fils hommes du
ras-le-bol fisc à la hausse et non
attendez pas le seul mais le fait de le
fait de rappeler les règles osterrieth
air de l'union européenne il est dans
son rôle ce n'est pas lui qui les a
choisis ce n'est pas lui qui les a
édicté et ce n'est pas lui qui a mandat
de les faire respecter mais en revanche
ça m'inspire une réflexion plus globale
pour rebondir sur ce que julie dit sur
les rapports de force elle a absolument
raison
les sociaux-démocrates des
sociaux-libéraux elle regardait
d'ailleurs avec intensité et les
centristes
aujourd'hui sont potentiellement menacés
mais justement c'est une raison
supplémentaire de faire cette europe
avec un ennemi clair que macro voudrait
construire mais c'est aussi une raison
supplémentaire de la libérer de la
gangue osterrieth r tant que l'europe
dans la vision des peuples monsieur
selvini ses amis ses nombreux amis en
france et ailleurs se confond avec la
gang osterrieth r elle n'a aucune chance
de regagner les spurs et lakers casitas
lien ils ont raison de refuser
je pense qu'il je pense qu'il le refuse
pour de mauvaises idées mais je pressens
attendait non c'est pas ça mais je pense
que red devis et ne vous rendez pas plus
bêtes que vous n'êtes guillaume roquette
je pense que réduire je pense je pense
que réduire l'europe à la défense de
l'austérité c'est un piège et
aujourd'hui c'est un piège mortel dont
il faut que les européens sortent sans
doute en reconstruisant l'europe avec
d'autres partenaires qu'avec l'allemagne
d'angela merkel andré bercoff
jean-michel nous dit n'allions pas que
le but des nationalistes européens et de
fragiliser le plus possible union
européenne peut-être qu'effectivement il
ya un objectif politique la chercher
dans le gréement italienne union
européenne qu'est l'union européenne non
mais il faut revenir quand même parce
que c'est très bien de l'enfer au traité
de rome quand même parce que c'est là on
va être un peu long rapidement
rapidement - de moi d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire je ne vais pas faire de
bashing de mots que ce combat chine n'a
pas besoin le pauvre pour le poufre il
est très très très bien lotis moi je
suis content de savoir que dans un union
européenne que quand même aujourd'hui il
faut le dire et le radoter le répéter à
eau aux auditeurs et aux téléspectateurs
du figaro c'est que dans cette union
européenne là l'europe des 5 les 50 ans
nous avons encore de paradis fiscaux non
mais on croit qu'on parle de quoi on
parle encore que dans ce pays si j'ai
beaucoup d'argent et je veux le mettre
adam lieu sûr je vais en belgique en
tout cas où je vais au luxembourg où il
est à l'admirable alcooliques anonymes à
jean claude juncker antoine représentant
admirable formidable de cette union
européenne que vous voulez défendre
contre les gens mais les gens n'en
peuvent plus les gens ont vu cette
espèce de plaisanterie total des signal
de son temps à autre et berri n'a rien
fait entre berck racette marty klein de
toute philosophie politique républicaine
et démocratique oui les majorités mais
majorité des gens comme ils peuvent
et rés quand on sait ça on dit pas comme
vous les gens comme si c'était un
argument d'autorité êtes prié non alexis
lacroix ces peuples il faut les
dissoudre comme disait bertolt brecht
c'est peuple vote mal c'est pas nous a
pas voté dans le sens que nous élites
intellectuelles des bons des sachants
ils votent pas dans le sens où il faut
les
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est une c'est un
point de vue c'est un point de vue
théoriquement la commission européenne
peut prendre des sanctions financières à
contre les italiens c'est prévu par les
traités jusqu'à 3 milliards d'euros
penser qu'elle le fera mais ce qui
m'intéresse pas c'est de savoir pourquoi
les italiens ont besoin de cet argent
c'est à dire que on s'intéresse aux
mécanismes financiers on dit ils vont
éclater le budget donc c'est pas bien
pourquoi l'europe à ce regard aussi
négative vis-à-vis du budget italien
c'est parce que on creuse les déficits
mais c'est aussi parce que la politique
prônée en italie ne satisfait pas des
observateurs à bruxelles
chelsea un revenu universel une baisse
des impôts qui étaient dans le programme
électoral de la culture et des impôts
c'est un revenu universel c'est si j'ai
bien compris et lui un abaissement la
possibilité de partir à la retraite plus
tôt ben c'est toute une série de mesures
alors on sait de relance je me sens la
consommation alors on nous explique que
ça a échoué partout et il est possible
que ces choux systématiquement regardons
moi je peux je je je je pense qu'on a
une
d'abord je pense que quand on parle de
l'europe et quand on parle de ont très
vite on dit les italiens en panne
d'abord et comme de grosse grosse nuance
entre ces différentes politiques ce ne
sont pas les mêmes hommes etc
je pense pas qu'on puisse considérer que
ce qui se passe en italie ce n'est qu'un
cas nationalisme est un populisme qu'il
faut comme ça d'un revers de la main
rayés des choses je pense qu'il faut
aller regarder pourquoi cette politique
est mise en place voilà il que donc il
faut peut-être laissé et donner leur
chance aux italiens et puis s'ils ont
envie de faire cette politique allons-y
on n'est pas hero 2 % du budget a été
arrêté eh bien on va l'arrêter ce sujet
sur cette main tendue
al ahly peuple italien et l'italie pour
reparler quelques minutes d' emmanuel
macron le prochain la république sera
donc en direct ce soir sur tf1 depuis le
charles de gaulle notre porte-avions qui
il eut au moins de polyphony ne
réchauffe pas le climat puisqu'il est
propulsé par une pile atomique
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour calmer
cette grogne dont on parlait en début
d'émission
qu'est-ce qui doit dire à votre avis
pour pour apaiser les français judith
waintraub si vous étiez son conseiller
ou sa conseillère que lui n'est rien
après on demandera aux conseillers
officiels qui est à l'essai la croix
rouge
je le dirai j'ai dit tout à l'heure
pourquoi son discours me semblait
voué à ne pas être cru être considéré
comme sincère quand il se flatte
quasiment d'être impopulaire parce que
il a pris des réformes qu'il l'était il
travestit l'avait la réalité pendant la
réforme de la sncf qui ont ce mode la
plus grande réforme structurelle qui les
fait jusqu'à présent il n'a jamais
manqué de l'approbation majoritaire de
l'opinion
c'était une première pour ce type de
réforme donc les français l'approuvent
quand il s'attaque vraiment aux
problèmes structurels de ce pays
l'ennui c'est qu'il ne fait pas
suffisamment
il ya des choses évidentes qu'il dit
être en train de faire comme par exemple
la suppression des régimes spéciaux de
retraite l'alignement des régimes c'est
pas du tout attaquer autant de travail
dans la fonction publique soyez des pans
entiers de structurer une offre à 102,4
ça mais je pense qu'ils ne peuvent s'en
tirer dès lors qu'il n'a pas les
résultats escomptés
il ne peut pas dire aux gens attendez
ça viendra c'était un discours qui
serait inaudible donc il ne peut que
s'en tirer quand en expliquant en quoi
il a l'intention de continuer à
transformer l'architecte heures de ce
pays puisqu'ils n'ont que le mot réforme
à la bouche qui met face et qu il les
explique andré de lacoste christophe à
nos internautes nous dit on sait déjà ce
que mc on va dire de poing ouvrez les
guillemets j'entends le mécontentement
mais trois petits points
c'est assez juste non vous désirez vous
demandiez à juniville robe secousses ou
y étiez que macron dit ce soir je vous
répondrais rien pourquoi rien il est
arrivé avec un grand espoir il s'agit
pas moi j'ai pas de ne pas les pats
manichéisme arrive et les trois
gagnantes espoir et beaucoup de gens
attendaient pour réformer effectivement
on sait très bien qu'il ya des réformes
à faire
on sait très bien que au delà des
anciens mon nouveau monde
il ya des choses à faire pour réformer
ce pays c'est pas nouveau et il arrivait
avec un vrai espoir et il arriva à
quelque chose et je pensais qu'il allait
le suivre lui même le disait la parole
rare c'est à dire contrairement à
françois hollande qui parlait tout le
temps à tout le monde et qui était le
commentateur d'ailleurs vous devrez
l'amener au payant là il y serait génial
évalué il s'est vanté
non mais il mène à la croix mais dis moi
je ferai face et déjà que milan qui
parlait de la parole rare c'est pas
nouveau mais il avait fait ça et on se
disait la jauge pour il fait les
réformes
il commence à l'affairé quand le
résultat et c'est vrai que ça prend du
temps on le comprend très bien je suis
passé par lapin qu'on tire le chapeau à
ce moment là il parle et là d'un coup
ils télé rend ce mémorial etc
il est devenu loquace il devenu bavard
il est devenu et les gens c'est pourquoi
cette eau pour lui il ne croit plus les
gens ne l'écoutent
plus en tout cas beaucoup de gens ne
l'écoutent plus alors qu'il écoutait au
départ c'est dommage
penser qu'ils feraient mieux de ne pas
parler le conseil de pilon reste valable
suis d'accord avec bercoff sur ce point
ses propres à jack qu'il en était
l'homme qui conseillait en communication
jacques chirac puis françois mitterrand
et puis l'a théorisé ses parodies dont
il avait théorisé judith s'en souvient
elle suivait déjà la politique à cette
époque
je voulais pas mais il est théorisé la
face à man j'avais a commencé à
travailler très tôt il accusé d'avoir
été la parole politique mais ya pas que
ça et je pense que et là on rejoint ce
que mathieu disait au tout début
macron est également la victime de gens
comme vous avec toute l'amitié que j'ai
pour vous je vous le dis qu'ils
ressassent dans une partie de l'opinion
de gauche et de droite confondues de
valeurs actuelles et du monde
diplomatique
cette idée qu'il serait l'émanation
d'une europe des puissants d'une robe
des banquiers d'une robe de l'argent aux
défis des finalités financière comme on
disait à l'époque de drummond voyez ce
discours-là drulhe attendre mais bien
sûr ce discours-là l'ajax son discours
la relaxe et sa liste il as envie
d'aller enlever drummond parce que
drummond c'est la france vit libre je
trouve ça minable et baroque et je le
non non non non ça pas de balises pour
la salle active à ces mines et puis je
vais vous dire quelque chose se dédit
smartphones que la filiation de manama
avec man travaux choisissez délibérément
un auteur antisémites à l'époque de
barrès disons ce discours je ne tiens
pas à ce discours là de délégitimation
gmac rond qui étend bourriner danton de
médias aujourd'hui après l'avoir encensé
il le il le lâche il le linge en
tambourinant cette idée qu'il serait
l'émanation des puissances financières
d'abord c'est un discours et rené parce
que il est l'émanation de lui même il
s'est créé lui même
d'une part je l'attendrai jallet se dit
ce que j'avais à dire je dois finir sur
ce discours je suis désolé je vais le
dire il ya un discours aujourd'hui chez
certains opposants d'emmanuel macron
donc ce n'est pas andré c'est des gens
de gauche c'est des gens de droite qui
finalement s'entendre sur le dos du
pouvoir aujourd'hui pour faire passer
emmanuel macbook ou pour une émanation
des féodalités financières bruxelloise
et mondialisée c'est un discours
dégueulasse déréaliser est absolument
délétère dans ses effets politiques je
le maintiens je pense qu'il faut le
combattre chaque fois qu'il était
annoncé sur twitter on pose la question
est-ce que vous regarderez
l'intervention d' emmanuel macron ce
soir sur tf1 au journal télévisé de 20h
vous le dites plutôt non peut-être que
vous considérez que vous ne pourrez
jamais regardé que chose de plus
intéressant du rahal excellent de vue il
y aura là
matthieu aron vous avez regardé
j'imagine professionnels gaz est obligés
à repenser viré non c'est comme ça je
rigole non moi ce qui me surprend quand
même alors je sais que c'est bon ça
parlait très loin ce que je dis mais
s'adresser au gilet jaune depuis le
charles de gaulle
il ya quelque chose qui va pas c'est
l'étonnant est quelque chose qui va pas
alors entendu vous allez me dire c'est
voilà c'est une coïncidence de dates de
calendrier qui sont jamais mais il
n'empêche il n'empêche que le président
aille dormir sur le charles de gaulle et
il passe du temps c'est très bien il est
totalement dans son rôle de présidente
du parlement cilia entendu qu'il parle
aux militaires tiens bien sûr ce matin
le premier ministre était sur une grande
chaîne de radio ce soir depuis le
charles de gaulle en est le président
enfin on se dit que s'il parle depuis ce
porte-avions c'est que ce qui arrive est
très grave
donc il ya quelque chose qui va pas
juste une analyse à mon avis de la
communication je pense qu'il ya un petit
décalage
c'était pour moi c'est un petit peu le
syndrome d'une machine s'est grippée qui
s'est grippée ces derniers mois et on ne
voit pas très bien ce qui va arriver à
faire en sorte que ça allait beaucoup
mieux
voilà j'ai dit à votre avis qui choisit
de faire ça depuis le charles de gaulle
parce que il y aura plus attendre demain
on serait où seraient rentrés oui ben je
crois qu'il est il est mal conseillé ou
alors il continua c'est pour être le
président des armées et vit évidemment
pire
on parlait d'armes et donc la déplorons
en tout cas de la puissance militaire de
la france mais je crois que c'est
surtout un sentiment de panique et une
improvisation qui explique ces faux pas
cette communication tous azimuts pour
répéter la même chose d'ailleurs
j'assume et je tiens le cap
eh bien il doit être conscient juste par
rapport à sare justement toi c'est que
il faut quand même dire que
contrairement à trump guillaume emmanuel
macron n'a pas la quasi totalité de la
presse française contre lui et c'est
heureux on ne peut pas dire que il y en
a qu'on soit là le martyr des médias -
comme il dit merci andré bercoff merci à
tous les quatre rendez vous ce soir à 20
heures pour regarder le président de la
république et rendez vous demain à la
même heure et au même endroit pour une
nouvelle édition de point de vue merci à
tous
[Musique]